il n'y a que le silence les pleurs le
corps de jean marie tjibaou et
rapatriées à l'aéroport de nouméa
le président du fln k s a été tué sur le
coup
son fidèle compagnon you when he yu hwan
et le suit le numéro deux du fln k s a
été touché le premier c'est après un
long coma qu'il a succombé
léopold j'aurais dié le numéro trois du
franc est effondrée ces cas présent tout
peut être remis en question et puis
c'est un début d'émeute et partisans le
tjibaou temps de lyncher les assaillants
voulaient c'est qu'on a rapatrié en même
temps que leurs victimes
l'un d'eux est mort c'est au bout de
cette route que l'attentât a eu lieu au
delà de ces barrages qui font de
gossanah et waderie là sur l'île d'ouvéa
un camp retranché
ici vivent les radicaux de la lutte
indépendantiste pierre on s'apprêtait à
commémorer le premier anniversaire de l'
attaque de la grotte quand deux hommes
ont sorti deux pistolets automatiques
fusillade avec les gardes du corps et
son mortellement blessé jean marie
tjibaou le président du fln ks est son
principal adjoint
higuain et léopold j'aurais dié le
numéro trois du parti kanak lui on est
sorti indemme il y a 6 mois nous avions
rencontré l'un des deux assassins un
pasteur devenu extrémistes du vélib et
là c'est son nom il affichait une
implacable résolution est tout un
responsable de tout ce qui n'est pas
fait à partir de
qu'est ce qui va se passer quand je sais
ce que c'est sûr et certain qu'il va
avoir une première fois mais la première
fois ça va se passer
pourquoi pas devant les armes utilisées
par jubilee et son complice oscar tango
qui provenaient de l' attaque contre
cette gendarmerie de fayaoué il ya un an
après l'assaut donné sur la grotte de
gossanah jubilee avait été emprisonné
puis libérées faute de charges dans son
dossier ce soir le haut-commissaire du
territoire a lancé un appel au calme
je souhaite que chacun dans ces heures
sombres restent calmes et s'associe au
deuil qui frappe les épouses les enfants
les parents et les amis de jean marie
tjibaou et de yuans et liu wen et de
tous les hommes de tous les femmes de ce
territoire épris de paix de justice le
23 novembre dernier tout le monde était
réuni à l'endroit même où vient d'avoir
lieu l'attentât tjibaou yéwéné yéwéné
mais aussi les extrémistes qui viennent
de les assassiner tous pleuraient les 19
kanaks de la grotte de gossanah
aujourd'hui les dissensions internes au
front indépendantiste ont brisé cette
union la mort à nouveau à frapper ouvéa